with the super bowl 55 just two days
away and counting law enforcement
agencies in the tampa area
are expressing concerns over lingering
threats of domestic terrorism
now we should say there is no specific
credible threat for the super bowl at
this time but the city
is being watched from the land the air
and the sea too
jamie yukas is on board a coast guard
patrol boat in tampa
with how agencies are managing these
very unique security challenges
the very tense time jamie good morning
we're glad they're there
absolutely gail good morning to you it's
not just about securing the football
stadium
the majority of nfl events are being
held here along the tampa waterfront
that has the coast guard on high alert
along with 70
condoms 7-0 other law enforcement
agencies
a thousand feet above tampa customs and
border protection agents are scanning
the skies
for anything suspicious anywhere there's
a large gathering of people
air marine is overhead providing that
safety and security
we flew with agent todd gale on game day
his team will be responsible for
securing a 30-mile restricted flight
zone
around raymond james stadium if it's a
serious threat
we are working hand in hand with the
department of defense and they can deal
with those threats as they deem
necessary
f-15 fighter jets will also be on
standby
prepare to shoot down any threatening
aircraft
this really does have to be a huge
coordinated effort between
so many different agencies yeah
absolutely
they take this very serious there are a
lot of components both in the air
on the ground and on the water that's
where the coast guard offers
another layer of protection tampa's
waterfront is hosting the nfl
super bowl experience drawing thousands
of fans each day
since the september 11th attacks the
super bowl has been treated as a
potential target
networks of security cameras watch every
move
incoming deliveries are scanned with
giant x-ray machines
tampa has hosted four super bowls before
but
this one presents a new challenge for
the city's top cop
chief brian dugan having the home team
here just creates a whole new dynamic
we've got to figure out a way to keep
everybody safe and secure but yet
be fan friendly at the same time do you
feel the pressure
yeah there's no doubt there's pressure
there it's more of a constant worry
do you have enough people have we
thought of everything chief dugan will
have the help of more than 500 homeland
security personnel
along with the nfl security team the fbi
and hundreds of police officers from
across the country
securing the stadium is the easy part
dugan told us
his biggest worry what could happen
outside of it
sunday night the number of parties that
have popped up
for sunday is just blossomed out of
control you're nervous
if the bucks win i'm nervous because i
just don't know what's going to happen
the crowd of people they're going to
want to celebrate and where are they
going to go
and you don't want anything to happen
right i don't want to see anybody get
hurt
there isn't no drone zone around the
football stadium
if operators are caught it is a 30
thousand dollar fine
the coordination takes a long time as
well officials have been on the ground
for about a year making sure everything
works out
that means people from l.a are already
here working out the plan
for next year anthony all right jamie
thank you